ladies and gentlemen the US has banned
light bulbs nice so uh so how you guys
doing
remember when I took AP environmental
science when I was in high school and
having to do a project where we have to
we went to our our middle school and
then convinced them that the swirly LED
whatever they are the better light bulbs
were in fact better and if we didn't do
that then you know we didn't get as good
a grade on the project and now I really
regret that because that was complete
propaganda paid for by college board Yep
this is kind of crazy though I mean the
the big story is they've banned
incandescent light bulbs you can only
now Buy LED light bulbs because they
last longer and use a lot less less
electricity it's kind of crazy I mean
how do they just ban something like that
isn't that an act of Congress they've
been phasing it in for years they've
been doing it for a while it's really
funny there's an episode of I I really I
think it was the show Castle where they
catch a guy who works for like the city
transit authorities like they've been
phasing out incandescent to compact
fluorescent he's selling the
incandescence overseas and like the
whole like the idea is that it's
ridiculous and why would that happen but
that's obviously you know between that
and your gas stove and they said the
we're gonna do it and they made us all
excited it's about the environment and
now like I know tons of people who will
see the other light bulbs and be like
okay no big deal like LED lasts longer
it's better for the environment and like
perhaps that's true I just don't like it
when the government is like so we're
going to introduce everything you want
to have an incandescent lights
look at old videos like if you have like
VHS tapes or anything like if you have
like home videos where there's lights on
out in the streets when you were growing
up unless all those lights are orange
and now like you don't see orange light
anywhere outside but look look my point
is how does the bite Administration just
unilaterally decree that a certain
product can no longer be sold but it
wasn't the vitamination
Administration on Tuesday down to two
new rules that set stricter energy
efficient standards for light bulbs
those standards will phase out the sale
of most new incandescent bulbs but
they've been trying to phase out and get
us the balls for years I mean well
before right in Congress will need to
pass a law Banning incandescent light
bulbs okay Joe Biden can't just decree
it it's the shadowy forces from Big bulb
that have been lost should we should we
Sue because we want our incandescent
light bulbs yes I mean and be like only
Congress can do it this is what I think
is the the weirdest thing about the
buyer Administration which is they were
like we're for the environment and
therefore we can justify anything we
want by saying it's for the betterment
of the environment you know what this
means you got a new shirt is you got to
come and take it shirt with it oh that's
a good idea the light bulb with the
light bulb on it I honestly don't and
the gas stove at all you put the light
bulb above a gas stove I bet someone
made that on the pizza oven yeah exactly
did it say if it was through executive
order because I mean I'm wondering it
just says he adopted rules because
that's I believe the actual supposedly
like what's supposed to be the purpose
of executive orders is to probably kind
of provide clarification for existing
things that are happening of how this is
how we're going to do it so and they
like she like I believe they probably
have been having legislation go for
forever so the pistol where I can
understand it the pistol price thing has
been rejected I believe judge States the
uh rule regulating pistol braces under
nfas is likely unconstitutional you
can't just keep Banning things like this
you can't just be like I hereby decree
so you know maybe we need to uh not
because I like incandescent light bulbs
actually I'm not a fan I like LED better
but uh it's it's the it's the principle
of the matter maybe maybe we should sue
the federal government and say you have
no authority to ban light bulbs in this
way protest put some incandescence up
here in the studio start manufacturing
our own incandescent so that we're not
selling them we're buying them we're
making our own yeah that's how you solve
these problems I guess the uh the the
the the the it's climate it's a climate
change agenda thing yeah but what I
think is that what it actually is is
um
you know you know what I think about the
security at airports why they make you
throw away your shampoo to sell more
shampoo yeah that makes sense because
they're they're like oh you you can't
bring that liquid in here because we
don't know what it is and then it's just
like you walk behind the security and
there's a whole bunch of really
dangerous chemicals for sale at like
these various news but they're small
quantities so it's safer they tell you
like what if I bought more though
there's this dude named Evan booth and I
I went and met up with him he did his
project where he was able to make
various weapons combustibles and things
like that within uh not not in an
airport but with things found within an
airport so you cross security you go to
the store what can you buy I won't say
them now on the show but yes we were
able to make
um improvised grenades using things you
can buy in an airport so the fact that
that research had been done this is like
12 years ago and that we have not seen
substantial moves on this what I see is
the reason the government made these
rules is because they're like it's going
to increase sales at these uh locations
in the airports which will generate more
tax revenue for us
simply put when when it comes to light
bulbs they're just looking at like how
can we generate more economic flow a
major shift in the economy will force
people to adapt it will change houses
it'll change standards and this will
force people to buy things when I still
remember like the first time I flew
during covid and like all the signs to
like make sure to to wash your hands and
they were all like sponsored by Purell
at the airport and I'm just like well
that's creepy right like it's it's
literally like an advertisement for the
company but it's put through actual
official airport policy right it's an
actual form that's put up by the airport
but in the corner there you get the
little Purell paid for it yeah exactly
so it's it's kind of government and
business working through many people
even really using condition light bulbs
more because I was just thinking about
it just it's so typical of government to
where they get to this point to where
the the essentially the private Market
is essentially adapted and then they
come in with a rule like look look what
we did and it's like you didn't really
do it I just I don't I don't feel like I
see incandescent light bulbs all that
often and they do that with like R22 a
couple years ago because of the ozone
layer a couple decades like a couple
decades ago like it's starting to face
out yeah like HVAC people used it so
they they phased it out so there's like
a black market for R22 to use I mean
they did that with stuff like child
labor laws it basically people weren't
really working their kids by the time
they started instituting those laws
because we had progressed economically
to a point where people don't want their
kids to work generally speaking so I
mean don't be wrong I guess it's sort of
good that they stopped some of those
kids but I mean I I don't know it's just
they come the government comes in and
then later it's like look what we did
and you're like well I mean the kind of
at the last minute the taking credits
for it when they didn't really do any of
the work in 2007 Obama said that he was
gonna immediately send a law to phase
out all incandescent light bulbs and
that was reversed under Trump and so now
the volume Administration was like and
we're back just payback like that's
we're so back baby we're so back
why this is not also like if LEDs are
better
presumably the consumer is like I see
the results and I want one like why do
you have to ban them that seems bizarre
to me they're like Trump and your jail
cell will have nothing but LED light
bulbs no incandescent no romantic
lighting for you yeah
that's actually why they've been trying
to stay in power for so long this is
like the one I'm telling you it's the
Inca it's the light bulb conspiracy it's
the P it's the forces of big bulb oh my
goodness so uh most what does it say uh
someone uh super chatted this is a good
one Kenneth Lauren saying are the bulbs
made in China or the USA so I just
Googled it and it says uh light bulbs
made in the USA do they exist it seems
like they don't since most consumers
look to purchase a cheaper bulb most
light bulbs are manufactured in China
where it is more cost effective so I
think that's just referring to
um incandescent light bulbs no I think
it's all of them all light bulbs are
made in China okay if there is any like
made in America light bulb can someone
please let me know on Twitter because I
will only buy their light bulbs like
that's bananas Public Square oh my gosh
Public Square I need a specific light
bulb vendor
yes there is the light bulbs made in the
USA Patriot Bowl light bulbs made in the
USA
Trump is like we're gonna be launching
light bulbs
uh him and the pillow guy can do that
together yeah that'd be good yeah I
don't know that that's a really good
question though because these moves
could be made to shift production and
and revenue generation and things like
that but the place that really doesn't
care about child labor I don't really
care about light bulbs to be honest I'm
just more so concerned that we are now
at a place where the the the federal
government has just been ruling by
decree just mandating so on the surface
it is but a simple story about light
bulbs that no one cares about
but when people ask how did it get so
bad
this is exactly it no one cares they
banned light bulbs No One's Gonna Go
protest over it but they do things like
this where they rule by decree a year
from now people will be like what do you
mean the government has always done this
so that's the Precedence too that's
right I mean this is the moment where I
want to say like everyone I think you're
right it would be nice to Sue I don't
know that I personally have the cash
reserves to fight the federal government
that can litigate you to death but it
would be interesting if we had these I
don't know Representatives who we could
call and be like hey how did this come
to be and I don't like it please fight
for my right to have an incandescent
light bulb if I so choose let me guess
though I don't know where you'd find
them maybe the House of Representatives
or the senate or something but hey gas
stove slap though so that's different
they hate them right yeah they hate they
hate the gas stoves yeah they're illegal
in Vermont apparently gastos are
incandescent light balls Lincoln isn't
light bulbs yeah that's because
fluorescent light bulbs oh man I feel
like Vermont is such a wild place but
fluorescent bulbs are really cool
because you can like rub your feet in
the carpet and then like grab it lights
up like a lightsaber you know and then
taking away fun and the kids go and
shatter them in the in the alley and the
dust comes out and they all laugh then
it goes in their lungs and they get
really sick Vermont do you see what
you're doing what you're keeping us from
yeah yeah
well uh I suppose the story is like a
mix of climate change stuff and
government overreach or whatever but I
figured we'd keep it light now we're
gonna go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member because
the member is only uncensored show will
be at 10 pm and we will take your
questions live and I'm gonna be writing
a song about insulin resistance so uh
come hang out all right I'm not your
buddy guy says Jack Smith is a political
Hitman he should be disbarred and sent
to prison for life
what's at the president this abuse of
power can cost your uh cost you your
life Behind Bars
can cost your life Behind Bars can send
you to prison
weird nug says Bud Light anyone LOL
who drinks Bud Light I've not actually
seen someone drink Bud Light in a minute
but we're in Maga country so I'm not
surprised is it still low are the are
the yes sales still down I saw a thing
that I read an article today that said
like some bars are like having to set it
up it's like it's a mystery logger just
to get rid of it like like they have to
put it on tap it's like it's a mystery
here we can't tell you what it is like
they had them all in a cooler and then
they had like blacked out this one shell
being like mystery it's funny my wife
just discovered the Bud Light
controversy yesterday and explained to
her and she was like yeah that is dumb
yeah so your wife is not into politics
that's amazing great she just found it
yeah she's my hero she's gonna get to
Target next and she's gonna be like did
you know
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time